in one cross test the hard to destroy  reptile scp-682 was made to face off  against  scp-689 the terrifying haunter in the  dark a statue that can induce death in  anyone who looks at it and then stops  paying attention the statue was placed  in 682's chamber and the lights were  turned off for five minutes when the  lights were turned back on 682 laid  motionless in a pile of dark gray goo  when a d-class was sent in to confirm  the kill 682 suddenly rose back up to  its feet and devoured him in an instant  two swift chomps with its razor-sharp  teeth and the d-class was history it  seems that 682 doesn't fit the same  definition of alive as us humans and as  a result was unaffected by the haunter  in the dark frighteningly 682 was also  smart enough to intuit 689's anomalous  ability and use this knowledge to play  dead and attempt escape